Forrest Gump turned 25 this year oh yeah
the movie actually inspired Gary Sinise
aka Lieutenant Dan to dedicate his life
to serving vets and military families
and only I joined Gary for this year's
feel-good holiday mission they've all
lost a parent in military service they
go through a lot of difficult difficult
things throughout the year but we bring
them together we show them a lot of love
these families sacrifice a lot we want
them to know we appreciate them my
grandma always used to say to me giving
back is actually a selfish thing because
it makes us feel better well what makes
me feel better seeing seeing these kids
haven't have a good time the smiles on
their faces say it all the love and
support these children of our fallen
heroes feel during the holidays is the
ultimate goal of the Gary Sinise
foundations snowball express this year
they're sending over 1,700 kids to
Disney World in Florida some getting
their first plane ride ever I was five
months pregnant with Ramon when my
husband was killed in action I like to
idolize my father because he was he
served his country well and he'll always
be my hero and I'd always know that he's
gonna be watching me in heaven we're
here because we lost their father and my
late husband four years ago
but I want to go some right and then see
some princesses one of the highlights of
this trip Gary rockin the base with his
lieutenant Dan man named after his
iconic Forrest Gump character are you
boys from in the world Alabama sir
twins it's that breakout role that first
inspired Gary to give back to our
military families well I promised myself
I was not gonna cry today but I don't
know that's gonna work we remember that
that's the important thing we want them
to know that we remember and we don't
take it for granted so wrapping our arms
around them is a really special
[Music]